I have a secret savings account that I'm
building up to be able to leave an
abusive marriage all I can say whether
it's a man or woman
[Music]
[Laughter]
none of my friends and family know that
I have been unemployed for two years and
live off less than $300 a month yes I've
gone to dinners and events knowing it'll
hurt my account only to keep my image my
father is a narcissist and left our
family without any money it's one of the
biggest inconveniences and I always feel
ashamed when I have to borrow money from
someone yeah we put so much importance
on money and self-worth and money yeah
like this person probably feels like
they're judged all the time my family
thinks I'm working as a social media
manager when I'm actually just an
employee on a call center
I don't openly share how much my student
loan debt has impacted my mental health
and triggers my depression because I
worry and assume people would judge me
and say that I deserve it when I was 16
I stole two thousand dollars over two
years at my last job and the thing that
scares me is that I feel no guilt for it
I don't want to go to jail and I don't
want people to think I'm a bad person
the money just solved so many of me and
my family's problems I don't think he's
a bad person
I know there's this kind of like
cut-and-dry idea of like if you break
the law you're a bad person but there's
a lot of gray area in that but you're
not a bad person you try to help your
family I think this person can take
comfort in that
I come off successful to everyone around
me but I'm struggling day by day trying
to fulfill a dream I don't think I'll
ever achieve maybe I should just give up
and I won't hits home my friends tell me
that all the time that they see me off
as being extremely successful and why
not I don't think anybody understands
how some of those big movies that I did
was because I felt extremely in the last
place they see me according to them
moving forward and doing all these big
things but to me it's just a struggle of
trying to stay afloat every day
it must be my own fault that I haven't
found a job yet I feel like a failure
when I ask for help my personally know a
lot of people in this exact same
situation where they feel like they put
all this work to go to college to you
know get a degree and they come out it's
just like what was all for if I can't
just get a job if I can't be a
functional adult like I'm supposed to be
you know I think oh we just want to let
this person know that you're alive
you're you're trying your best you're
it's okay to ask for help
you know and you're not a failure hey
guys Jason from Jubilee here we just
want to say thank you so much for
watching another episode of seeking
secrets we will also want to say a big
shout out to our sponsors simple habit
you know I really believe that
meditation is a great way to work
through some of our questions and our
issues it's not so much to think about
it more but actually to take a breath
and take a step back simple habit is a
mental wellness app that has guided
meditations and therapy if you're having
trouble at work if you're having trouble
sleeping if you have just gotten over a
breakup these are all different things
that you can actually find specific
meditations on for all of our viewers we
actually have a special link below that
if you use it to download the app you
actually get seven days of premium
content for free as always we want to
say thank you so much for watching and
we'll see
next time